is Star Trek Legacy inevitable
is it when and not if we get this show
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
I think it's fair to say that following
the end of Picard season 3 we all assume
we're going to get Star Trek Legacy but
the words coming out of Paramount and
even from Terry metallis himself is that
this is not in development there is no
plan to actually bring Star Trek Legacy
back and we will not be seeing the
Adventures of Captain seven of nine
aboard the Enterprise G
but
when strange new worlds came out didn't
we get told basically the same thing at
first
hmm well I've been speaking to somebody
that works in marketing and actually
used to work a Paramount Pictures and
they've told me that actually all was
not what it seemed when it came to
Strange New worlds that actually the
strange new worlds was always the plan
when the Enterprise appeared in
Discovery season two it was quite a
surprise
it's the USS Enterprise nobody was
expecting it but it worked brilliantly
Anson Mount as Captain Pike was
instantly loved and we got to see a
little bit of the pre-kirk Enterprise
now following the end of Discovery
season two there was then a massive
campaign by the fans to bring strange
new worlds back and we eventually were
victorious because Paramount yielded and
decided to Green Light the show
or did they
well according to the person I've been
speaking to actually it was always the
plan to bring us a strange New World
Series the Anson Mount was on board with
that from day one and actually it was
one of the only reasons when he agreed
to do the show Discovery in the first
place this was always a bit of a
marketing Ploy by Paramount to get us
all feeling engaged in the show let's
tease the fans with something and then
let's talk about a possibility of a show
then let's see the fans getting all
excited demanding a show and then
eventually when we give it them we sound
like we're listening to our audience we
sound like we're actually the good guys
in this situation and actually then
there can be some positivity around Star
Trek which at times they've struggled
with under Alex kurtzman now the person
I speak to they don't work at Paramount
anymore but when I sort of suggested
this they gave me a right little smile
and said well they've done it once why
wouldn't they do it again and after we
actually saw the final episode of Picard
season three they said look they don't
go into this much detail if there isn't
a plan they don't do things like
renaming the Titan the Enterprise unless
there's a plant we saw Raffi as number
one seven of nine as the captain the
whole thing about bringing Q back again
that's a lot of detail for something
unless there's a plan so in this
person's opinion professional opinion
it's when not if we get Star Trek Legacy
now the fans would be very very happy
about that because we want some more
25th Century Adventures this is our Star
Trek it's in the time frame we love
there's been a lot of effort through
Picard season three to sort of reset
some of the mistakes from seasons one
and two of Picard and get us back to a
Star Trek in the 25th Century that we
recognize
now you can see that with a lot of the
ships design a lot of the designs the
ships storylines etc etc
they've done all of that work
for a reason
now the show that we know we're getting
at the moment is Star Trek Academy and
it's pretty much certain that's going to
follow on in the 32nd Century now a lot
of people are against this idea I keep
calling it Star Trek 90210 and I'm
poking fun a little bit because it's
going to be a bunch of teenagers running
around having wild adventures but I
genuinely hope that they actually do
something brilliant with that show and
I've said even if I think it's a
terrible idea and I can't quite see how
they're going to do it there's been lots
of other projects over the years that
sound like terrible ideas but turn out
to be brilliant I've been talking about
Firefly a lot recently you break down
the synopsis of firefly and it sounds
stupid
but it's 14 episodes of sci-fi gold
and who knows maybe Star Trek Academy
will be exactly the same I hope so and I
will be watching it with an open mind
you will not be getting me saying that
this is going to be a lot of work crap
because I don't say that anyway
before the show comes out I will watch
it and I will tell you what I think but
all of that goes on in the 32nd Century
now I want to see what happened in 32nd
Century I like all the future I like all
the spaceships and things and I I like
the idea of the Federation being rebuilt
so there's some interesting stuff going
on there if done well but we want to see
the 25th Century we want to see the
characters we love we want to see Wharf
and Deanna and all these other
characters potentially return we want to
see cameos from Deep Space Nine and more
Voyager we want to see O'Brien how they
didn't get O'Brien in Picard season
three I've no idea so hopefully Legacy
though could bring us all of those
things that we so desperately want we
want more of Picard season three
now it's a shame they rename the Titan
Enterprise I've done another video
talking about that I can't help it I
don't like it but
I still want to see Adventures aboard
the Enterprise even if it is
that ship so what do I think are we
going to get Adventures aboard the Star
Trek Enterprise G
I'm pretty certain that the old adage
there's no smoke without fire fits this
situation beautifully because they are
going to be working towards this because
they've done too much work setting up
Legacy for it to not then get made I
think there will be a couple of years
until we see it if you actually remember
Discovery season 2 aired in 2019 but
strange new worlds didn't Premiere until
2022.
now I'm also here in rumors the strange
new worlds may not go beyond the three
seasons now there are reasons for this
but mainly there's already some concerns
at Paramount that strange new worlds is
starting to step on the toes of the
original series and that there's only so
far they can go before trekkies
basically turn on the project
I think they've already seen an element
of that with how strange new worlds
ended in season one with the emergence
of Kirk on screen
Enterprise this is Captain James T Kirk
of the USS Farragut offering assistance
fans didn't respond to that quite as
well as they'd hoped
overall I loved the Strange New World
Series and I'm really hoping season two
is just as good
but they do need to fix a few of those
little problems and if that is the case
and strange new Wheels doesn't go past a
third season could Star Trek Legacy be
the series that very quickly replaces it
in that case there would be about that
three-year Gap and maybe we would see
Star Trek Legacy in 2025 2026 I firmly
believe that that is the plan and again
from what I've been told by an Insider
who at least used to work at Paramount
it does seem to be that they've done it
before and they're not afraid to do it
again
and since recording the language seems
to be changing a little bit Alex
kurtzman seems to be admitting that this
is the plan after all
but guys what do you think get into the
comments and tell me exactly what you
feel about the Star Trek Legacy idea are
you gonna be happy with a Star Trek show
set in the 32nd century and one set in
the 25th Century for a few years now
they've been trying to set up a
different show for different
demographics of Star Trek a kids show
the lower Dex cartoon strange new worlds
Discovery all really aimed at slightly
different types of people
are you happy for that to continue and
even if Starfleet Academy isn't really
the Star Trek for you
perhaps Star Trek Legacy is and that's
okay
personally I'm okay with all of it
except discovering I've never liked that
but guys get into the comments and tell
me exactly what you're thinking if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out and you'll never
miss any of our new videos also if you'd
like to wander over to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack you can see most
of our new videos first and without the
adverts for a small contribution as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next time
foreign
[Music]